this is model life I guess the model
life looks good on Ireland Baldwin's but
sometimes her famous family doesn't
exactly know how to handle it
check out the blonde beauty in all her
glory posing nearly naked on Instagram
the 23 year old model wearing nothing
but an itty-bitty g-string which got
quite a reaction out of her dad Alec he
commented I'm sorry what and there's
more
Ireland's uncle Billy Baldwin also
chimed in writing tough one for uncle
Billy to like hashtag awkward what it's
not the first time the 30 rock actor has
shared his opinion about his daughter's
racy snaps here's Ireland straddling a
motorcycle last year Alec winced in the
comments no just no Ireland has always
been outspoken especially when it comes
to social media and scrutiny of her body
she opened up to ET in 2015 about
balancing the good with the bad
I'm so grateful I mean I really see the
bad stuff over there and I mean it's
just it's crazy to me how honestly I get
so much positive feedback towards the
things I say and do and things I come
out with and just whatever it is it's
mostly positive which is such a
beautiful thing and I don't even see the
negative or read the negative anymore
it's like a huge family you know just
big supportive family and it's really
cool
[Music]